[Musique]
alors quelles sont vos croyances quels
sont vos croyances sur la réalité c'est
une question que l'on se pose peut qui a
généralement on est un peu comme saint
thomas on croit ce que l'on voit je vais
vous exposer certaines de mes croyances
sur la réalité elles pourront paraître
déroutante ou contre intuitive
en tout cas le sont toujours pour moi ce
sont des croyants ce sont mes croyances
donc ne me croyez pas considérez les
comme une hypothèse et si hypothèse la
réalité n'existait pas et si hypothèse
la réalité était une illusion dont nous
faisons l'expérience et si oui pourquoi
alors il ya quelques années encore je
considérais cette réalité celle que nous
partageons comme la seule réalité est la
seule réelle mais ça ça c'était avant un
voyage un voyage qui a profondément
modifié mon rapport au réel alors je
vais vous raconter cette petite histoire
nous sommes en 2013
j'arrive en toscane dans une villa
magnifique villa avec au premier étage à
un balcon qui donne sur la mer il faut
savoir quelque chose sur moi c'est que
je suis sujet au vertige mais là
franchement au premier étage
je pense pas risquer grand chose je
m'avance sur la balustrade et je fais
l'erreur de regarder vers le bas
grosse erreur je suis tétanisé mes
intestins se noue mes jambes tremblent
et je baisse instinctivement mon centre
de gravité mais je suis déjà à 6
mais demain veulent attraper le rebord
en pierre de la balustrade
mais ce qu'elle touche c'est le bois de
mon bureau
le mois le bois de mon bureau de mon
appartement parisien où je me trouve
réellement jean lèvres alors de ma tête
le prototype de locustes rift ce casque
de réalité virtuelle d'un nouveau genre
je me demande bien ce qu'il vient de se
passer
où j'ai peur de comprendre mes sens
montre on paie mon cerveau m'a trompé et
je viens de faire un bond dans le futur
le futur de la réalité virtuelle qui
délivre enfin son graal la sensation de
présence
j'étais chez moi à paris dans mon bureau
mais j'étais aussi là-bas en toscane
je savais que j'avais un casque de
réalité virtuelle sur la tête
pourtant mon expérience du vertige était
réel je l' ai vécu jusque dans mon corps
et jusque dans mes tripes je venais tout
simplement de faire l'expérience réelle
d'une illusion
l'expérience réelle d'une illusion alors
forcément je me suis demandé si aussi
cette réalité était une illusion
j'ai décidé d'avoir une approche
pluridisciplinaire et d'être ouvert et
flexible d'esprit donc je veux aller
chercher l'information et l'expérience
dans les domaines aussi bien
scientifique caisse haute et riku
spirituel je me suis plongé dans la
physique quantique
le yoga le bouddhisme zen les rêves
lucides la gravité quantique à boucles
ou le chamanisme et ce qui m'a fasciné
c'est qu'en fait c'est ces disciplines
sont autant de cartographie différentes
pour expliquer le territoire le réel et
elles sont plus de points communs que de
différences
l'une d'entre elles s'est effectivement
nous sommes dans une grande illusion une
illusion dont la réalité ultime et au
delà de notre perception sensorielle
mais paradoxalement
les cartes qui ont le plus qui m'ont le
plus fait peur d'un côté qui m'ont le
plus
transfiguré c'étaient les cartes
scientifique c'étaient les cartes qui
qui qui ont été le plus difficile à
intégrer par mon cerveau pourtant
fortement logique et rationnel alors je
vous en donner un petit exemple
mais d'abord je vais vous poser des
questions en ayez pas peur il ya n'y a
pas de piège vous pouvez élever l'âme
donc parmi vous qui croie que la terre
est ronde qui croient que la terre
tourne autour du tourne sur elle-même à
1600 km heure qu'elle tourne autour du
soleil à cent mille kilomètres heure et
que le système solaire lui même se
déplace à 800 milles kilomètres heure
dans l'espace c'est le cas vous aussi
levé la main tenant qui croient qu'il
existe un double de vous quelque part
qui assiste aussi à ce thème quelques
mains mais y en a beaucoup moins
en effet et pourtant la science nous dit
qu'il ya des univers multiples que notre
univers ne serait pas le seul qu'il y en
aurait une infinité dans lesquelles vous
aussi vous existez vous auriez le même
passé mais pas forcément le même futur
et ce serait aussi des versions uniques
comme vous aurez bien sûr c'est contre
intuitif mais en tout cas si vous ne
croyez pas ici dans un des multivers
vous me croyez
alors pourquoi pourquoi c'est difficile
à croire parce que souvent on pense que
les multi d'air sont une théorie et
c'est là qu'il faut le faire la
distinction entre une théorie et les
conséquences d'une théorie prenons
einstein et son concept et sa théorie de
la relativité générale il y avait des
conséquences à ces théories einstein lui
même avait compris qu'une des
conséquences de cette théorie
c'était le trou noir mais lui il n'y
croyait même pas il savait que j'étais
une des conséquences de cette théorie
mais ils n'y croyaient pas pourtant
quarante ans plus tard on les a trouvés
idem une conséquence de la théorie de la
relativité générale ce sont les ondes
gravitationnelles
on a mis 100 ans à les trouver on les a
trouvés l'an dernier et le prix nobel de
physique de cette année et justement
aller à ses découvreurs et vous l'aurez
compris les multis hier ne sont pas une
théorie les multis verts sont une
conséquence d'une théorie et pas
seulement d'une théorie de deux théories
de la relativité générale et de la
mécanique quantique qui sont les deux
théories qui explique aujourd'hui le
mieux le réel nous sommes donc des êtres
multidimensionnelle qui vivons une
version unique de nous alors qu'est-ce
qu'il ya encore comme illusion nous
faisons l'expérience mais il y en a
beaucoup
il y en a il y en a plein en fait il y a
le temps et l'espace le temps et
l'espace sont une illusion issus des
fluctuations du chant quantique
il y a aussi la séparation la plus
grande illusion et réalité serait la
séparation
vous avez l'impression que je vous parle
et que vous écoutez selon moi en fait ce
serait la conscience unique qui se
parlent à elle même à travers
différentes partie d'elle-même dans la
physique quantique aussi on retrouve ce
côté de d'unicité que tout est lié
on appelle ça l'intrication quantique et
l'intrication quantique depuis le big
bang
tous seraient liés donc on le voit il y
a beaucoup d'illusions dont nous faisons
l'expérience ce qu'il compte c'est
l'expérience mais le concept dans tous
ces concepts le concept qui a le plus
bouleversé non expérience du réel c'est
celui selon lequel nous serions
créateurs de notre réalité nous serions
créateurs de notre réalité
là encore on peut retrouver des exemples
en physique quantique en physique
quantique
il n'ya pas d'observateurs neutres le
principe d'observateurs n'existe pas le
simple fait d'observer la réalité l'a
créé le simple fait d'observer la
réalité en créer une version unique dont
on va faire l'expérience est selon moi
nous avons tous un filtre unique
création de réalité ce sont nos
croyances nos croyances filtre en même
temps qu'elle crée simultanément la
réalité que vous a dont vous allez faire
l'expérience
alors à quoi ça sert tout ça si on
comprend et si on y croit on peut
comprendre qu'en fait le monde extérieur
et ça c'est l'une de mes croyances le
monde extérieur est une boucle de
biofeedback de nos croyances
c'est dire que nous vivons dans la
réalité ce que nous croyons sur nous à
quoi ça sert si vous n'aimez pas ou si
vous avez des choses la réalité de la
réalité a changé dans votre expérience
plutôt que de vouloir changer l'autre
plutôt que de vouloir changer le monde
ce qui reviendrait un peu à gribouiller
en fait un miroir le but serait plutôt
d'aller en nous regardez les croyants à
ce qui nous limite et en changeait
consciemment pour en faire l'expérience
dans le miroir du monde
les croyances les croyances serait donc
la carte qui permettent d'explorer le
territoire du réel mais la carte n'est
pas le territoire
soyons donc flexible sur nos croyances
acceptons de les regarder et d'en
changer pour vivre une expérience de la
réalité illusion bien meilleure pour
nous car pour moi la réalité serait en
fait il est effectivement une réalité
virtuelle biologique
une projection de la conscience dans la
réalité physique qui n'a d'autre but qui
n'a d'autre but que de nous faire
comprendre qui nous sommes vraiment des
créateurs conscient et si pour saint
thomas on croit ce que l'on voit je vais
vous laisser sur cette dernière
hypothèse et si l'on voyait ce que l'on
croyait
merci
[Applaudissements]